my body is really sore and that really
was the hardest workout I think I've
ever done I'm not a personal trainer I'm
just a regular person the last thing I
want to do is 100 pull-ups
it is day one of the pull-up challenge
from doing a hundred pull-ups every day
for 30 days this challenge started a
couple years ago I wanted to do a
fitness project for BuzzFeed where I
gained as much muscle mass as possible I
was always super skinny and I always had
body image issues so I gave myself 12
weeks to do it and I gained about 20
pounds and then throughout the year I
kept it on and I was really impressed
with how much stronger I looked and felt
so I wanted to sort of challenge myself
again and see what else I could do I'm
pretty excited I'm nervous I'm scared I
don't even know if I can do 100 pull-ups
most I've ever probably done was like
fifty in one gym session and 100 super
daunting and I'm grossly competitive so
if I can't do 100 I'm gonna be so
frustrated with myself since it's my
very first day I want to see how much I
can improve over the next 30 days so I'm
sort of going for time today I want to
see how quickly I can do my hundred
pull-ups about halfway through on the
very first day my arms were completely
dead so I'm not looking forward
stay what I'm gonna do it we'll see what
happens luckily I finished all 100
pull-ups I was super proud of myself
it took me about 54 minutes to do 100
pull-ups which i think is pretty good I
want to keep time because I know I'll be
able to cut down on my very last day and
I want to see how much time I can
actually cut my very first set I did 16
pull-ups hoping to get that to 25 or 30
I think 30 would be awesome and yeah day
one is complete 29 more to go
I have a feeling I'm gonna be very sore
tomorrow I don't think I've been the
sort in a very long time basically my
whole upper body I don't know can I do
this for 29 more days
okay threes workout is officially done
last 25 were really difficult almost
couldn't do it I almost came back a
second time today it's okay if I fail
but it's also I don't know I'm gonna
push myself and see how far I can go
this challenge was gonna be a really big
undertaking so I wanted to make sure
that I was doing it correctly so I
reached out to my friends at Soho
strength lab which is a gym in New York
and we realized that if I was gonna do
all of these pull-ups I wanted to make
sure that I had different variations of
the pull-ups so I could do a regular
pull up this way but I could also do
parallel grip or reverse grip and that
way I wouldn't put too much strain on my
body and then we also figured out that
if I was gonna do all these pulls I
needed to have a lot of pushes in my
workout as well so when I was doing 100
pull-ups I was also in between doing
some push-ups we're doing handstands
just so my muscles could get a break and
I wasn't just overworking them because I
was doing this challenge I actually
didn't want to change too much about my
diet I just wanted to see what the
pull-ups would add or change to my body
I did want to be careful about the
number of carbs that I was putting into
my body so I didn't have any cars with
dinner and then for for breakfast
that was when I mostly got my carbs just
because I needed that energy before and
after my workouts it's day four and I
don't want to go to the gym
I am tired and sore but I signed up for
the challenge and I think it'll get
better the next couple days were
actually a lot harder than I thought
they were gonna be because my entire
upper body was so sore my abs were sore
it hurt when I laughed when I coughed
and I started getting calluses all over
my hands which made it even harder to
grip the pull-up bar I thought to myself
if my body's gonna be this sore and it's
only day four into this challenge there
is no way I'm gonna make it to day 30 so
that was not looking forward to the rest
of it it's getting easier to be honest
at least compared to the first couple
days okay five is done 25 left week two
was a little different my body stopped
getting really sore which was awesome I
was sort of getting used to all the
pull-ups and that made them a lot easier
to do I've always struggled with not
knowing how far to push myself so one
day 9 I wanted to really see how far I
could go so I did the hundred pull-ups
but I also did a hundred push-ups on top
of that just to see if I could do it and
surprisingly I was able to do it it took
a little while but I did it all in one
gym session and that was incredible
because to me it sort of told me that
the project was working because there's
no way I would have been able to do that
before this challenge day 11
early in the morning ready for the
challenge feel-good nuts or the biggest
thing for me with this challenge is
they're only like to pull up spots at my
whole gym and I always feel so guilty
using them so I sort of made the the
city of New York my gym at some points I
would go to the park to do the pull-ups
or I would use scaffolding and do the
pull-ups just to finish my workout and
that way I wouldn't cheat myself out of
not finishing off one hundred I don't
know I just have to get creative with it
because I feel so bad about taking up
the pull-ups by every single time in the
gym
[Music]
[Applause]
just finished day 15 that means them
literally halfway through the challenge
already this is crazy because two years
ago I couldn't do a single pull-up and
now I'm doing a hundred a day and I just
did it for 15 days there's a point
during the end of the third week when I
was in a separate BuzzFeed video the
video was taken from a different angle
of where I ever saw myself this camera
was set really far away
I got to see myself from an angle I
could see that my arms were like the
biggest they had ever been I was just so
impressed with myself because I was
actually seeing results it is day 20 and
I am 2/3 of the way through the project
so I thought I'd celebrate by doing
hundred pull-ups and 100 pushups today
just to compare myself to that first
week when I did it to see how much I've
improved it actually went really well I
did it in the same amount of time it
took me to do the just a hundred
pull-ups in day one so I'm definitely a
lot faster at this and that's like exact
proof that I had gotten stronger and was
able to do this so I originally wasn't
going to say anything about it but
there was one day last week when I
didn't complete all hundred pull-ups I
don't know I was just super tired my
body was exhausted
I wasn't feeling well I've done enough
research about fitness to know that if
your body is not feeling well you
shouldn't push yourself I wanted to
listen to my body so I only did thirty
that one day and I was really frustrated
with myself and embarrassed I didn't
want everyone to know that I had failed
I sort of looked at it as failing I
wouldn't even call it failing because
I'm still completing the challenge
almost every single day it's just one
day I couldn't do it and I was so glad
that I didn't finish because for the
next day my body was absolutely ready
and I was able to do all hundred the
next day so the very last day of the
challenge was pretty big for me I knew
that I wanted to go into it and do all
hundred pull-ups as quickly as I could
because I wanted to compare that time to
the very first day and on the first day
I did all hundred pull-ups in 54 minutes
on the very last day I completed all 100
in 21 minutes and I was just so
incredibly proud of myself because they
just showed how strong I had actually
got I am officially done with the
challenge I did not really think I was
gonna make it this far I don't know I
just keep thinking - two years ago I
literally couldn't do a single pull-up I
know it's really easy to look at some of
these fitness videos and fitness
projects online and think yeah that's
great for that person but like what
about me I am that person who used to
ask those questions I would see other
people's body transformations and I
would just think like that is honestly
incredible for them but I could never do
that but here I am I'm literally that
person who did that there were actually
some pretty big changes in my
measurements from before and after the
challenge my weight actually went up by
about half a pound which was incredible
I saw that my body fat percentage went
down to ten point nine percent instead
of the thirteen point eight percent it
was originally and also I saw that my
chest got a lot bigger and my biceps got
bigger and my shoulders got bigger - I'm
not a personal trainer I'm just a
regular person and some days I don't do
everything that I should do but it is
not easy at all it's a lot of hard work
a lot of willpower and you may not like
it then but if you have a fitness goal
or if you want to gain muscle if you
want to lose weight if you want to do
anything like just look at my progress I
couldn't do a single pull-up two years
ago and I just did a hundred of them
everyday for 30 days so you can do it
too
[Music]
[Music]